yeah i i wonder if fred's going to do
another
uh coco company
oh he's got to i think he is he'll do
another drop
a little comedy drive i was how i didn't
i wasn't i was out of town uh how do you
how was his first comedy night you know
freddy's funny he is he's a natural he's
gonna be all right uh it was great he he
gradually got better that's what it was
it was like he opened you know he'll
normally host a comedy show
and he made it like to host the comedy
show you also kind of have to be funny
word and then he just
that fearless thing is a real thing bro
like when you don't when you don't feel
like you got nothing to lose you just
are great and he's also he's not afraid
to uh to look stupid or to like fail
from a comedy perspective and he's just
that's what makes him so great he's like
yeah you can get me or like i can follow
my facebook i'll be right back up you
know like keep that same energy if
you're talking [ __ ] about me while i'm
down and he keeps that he does that with
everything he does acting comedy yeah
rapping
raising his kids